well it was it was very wonderful for
whites to to to recognize
the tragedy of the past and to want to
make up for it
but in the process
they again
in a sense duplicated they took our fate
out of our hands
they said to us we can fix you better
than you can fix yourself
we're the actors and so you can hear the
the white supremacy in this form of
liberalism
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here living
inside this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
to you the issues and awareness that you
need to know about the violence on the
south side of chicago but also to raise
as much money as possible to build a
community center on this much needed
block called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs took the o in his name and
started calling it o block we decided
we'd like the o but we're going to
change it to opportunity block i want to
thank fox for giving me the opportunity
every single day to bring you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions on
matters as it relates to chicago
violence and issues across our great
country
right now i'm in chicago and i'm making
my last stand against post-60 liberalism
i'm on this roof until i raise the money
to build this community center which i
see as a place of transformation
as well as a place of hope for my fellow
south siders
the reason why i believe building this
building is so crucial is because so
many children born here
have known nothing but violence and
poverty
they know for they have no frame of
reference to understand that there's a
world out there that things don't
have to be the way they always have been
and that the way that they are this is
why i'm honored to have shelby steele
the writer
filmmaker
as my guest on rooftop revelations mr
steele was born on the south side and
grew up here
and the reason why i wanted to talk to
him is because he knew this world before
post-60 liberalism
or what many refer to as
the great society programs
before they came in and eventually
destroyed this neighborhood
he saw how blacks here thrived and how
all kids of
all kinds of businesses were here
and the community was thriving and
families were together
so i'm glad to have mr steele on our
show mr steele thank you welcome to
rooftop revelations
thank you so much for having me it's an
honor to be here
absolutely let's jump right in i want to
ask you some questions i'm a i'm an avid
fan and a reader of all your materials
all your books and i'm excited that you
got a new book that's going to be coming
out soon
but i want to ask you what was it like
on the south side of chicago before
government decided to come in to the
lives of blacks and attempt to socially
engineer
their way upward what was it like
well i suppose looking back from uh
from today
it was a kind of golden age almost this
was
after the war posted 50s 60s
the government had no interest in
socially engineering
black americans anywhere
we were pretty much left to our own
devices
within the boundaries of segregation so
we were limited in that regard
uh and yet within the community itself
there was an ethos of responsibility and
a new possibility in a in a post
a post-war community
and uh so the focus was on what we could
do for ourselves and we did many
great things as
i mentioned not long ago
on the street i grew up on a friend down
at the end of the block his name was
melvin van peebles
later on he invented independent
filmmaking in america in the world
uh there was a
girl named linda hawkins became a phd
biologist there was
any number of people who who came out of
this neighborhood that was that was
segregated
uh in working class at that poor
uh but everybody in that sense was on
their way up there was an idea that we
would take ourselves up it was mutual
respect
uh the family structure was was
supported the marriage rates uh were
higher than in in many white communities
uh and we were on the way uh
and so it was a
a a great place for me to grow up i i
never saw a pistol
uh until i was probably 18 or 19 years
old
i never heard a gunshot
um
you you showed respect in the community
and
you could be disciplined by other
people's parents who would who would say
well i'm gonna tell your mother on you
and mean it absolutely
there was a sense that we were we were
an important people on our way up
right so it sounds like
before post-60 liberalism
we were moving upward so what is it
that you feel happened in the 60s
that changed all of that
we ran into white guilt
by that i mean
white america did something extremely
brave courageous honorable in every way
uh in the in the as the civil rights
movement began to build in the 50s and
60s
that they acknowledged that that the
america had committed as an original sin
and racism
slavery segregation
oppression uh in in a thousand ways i
mean our lives were really circumscribed
by by white racism
when america finally acknowledged that
and admitted that
it became interested in its own
redemption
in its own
moral legitimacy
and it began to build programs the great
society and so forth
that showed america to be
concerned with redeeming itself from its
history
not in
asking for development from the black
community
well in a sense our fate was stolen from
us as blacks
was taken away and used to re-establish
the moral legitimacy of whites
well it was it was very wonderful for
whites to to
recognize
the tragedy of the past and to want to
make up for it
but in the process they again
re in a sense duplicated they took our
fate out of our hands
they said to us we can fix you better
than you can fix yourself
we're the actors and so where you can
hear the the white supremacy in this
form of liberalism
the idea that whatever happens to you
black people we do it you you will not
be actors in your own in your own faith
that's what then took the steam
the focus of
out of
away from blacks and into the larger
community and we began immediately in
the mid 60s to fall into decline and we
have been declining ever since and today
we are behind whites and we were back in
the 60s
you know mr steele you talk about you
know being behind and i've read in some
of your books and i've heard you in some
of your lectures talking about
um a permanent black underclass that was
created by post 60s liberalism
was there a a black
underclass before that
there was no permanent black underclass
i never heard of a black underclass
until the work of william julius wilson
came out in the 1970s so important
sociologists studying the inner city
life and
he was sort of the first to document
the the burgeoning of this this black
underclass
the the word itself
it suggests that this was a class of
helpless people
uh and and and it is it is helplessness
is is the the marker there's people who
are stuck
in poverty and and and have no no way
out
uh so that that became the the
is the term that is still with us the
underclass still suffers from
uh yet it is supported by liv by this
again paul sixties liberalism which
which now as far as i'm concerned uh the
the word that comes to mind is it
enables weakness
in blacks
it it rewards us
for being irresponsible
we're not taking it says there's no
degree of
irresponsibility that you can fall into
that we won't reinforce with public
money
we will reinforce you for that
we won't we won't ask you to do better
and we will support you when you do
worse and so you get a people falling
out of the working class
falling out of family life
falling away from the the institutions
that uh that make a community strong
and then you're left with an underclass
you know
you know mr i'm on this roof
and
i'm here on the roof because we've had
70 years of decay in this community
uh your former community
and people you know they laugh and mock
and they talk about me being here
but in a way i really feel like it's a
sign of desperation how desperate things
have gotten
and
have we really
come to a place in america
where i and my staff feel that the only
thing to reverse the decline
is through extreme measures like me
being on a rooftop
i mean
i think we have the tools you've seen
our work firsthand
so you know we really do mean business
but but we lack the funds what what do
you think about just the work that we're
trying to do to turn this thing around
on the south side of chicago and become
a model for america
well i think you're god's gift right now
too uh to black america to to the black
community across all across america
because we've gotten this this terrible
terrible idea coming out of the 60s
that our dependency on a larger society
is justice
and that what we needed would be doing
is protesting and we need black lives
matter and we need black anger
and we need black identity and we need
all these things
no those things those things assuage us
as we decline
but we need a traditional
family
values a mother and a father no social
programs
will ever will ever uh substitute for
that
uh and that's we we need that
that sort of common sense
uh
responsibility for our own fate and the
society needs to
don't just keep giving us things more
and more things
ask
more from us
and we need to ask more from ourselves
uh i think america's patience is going
to run out
pretty soon but the work that you do my
friend
is the future
uh you are you are building us putting
us back together
uh you are focusing on all these things
you're asking something of the people
you're trying to help
that's the secret
and then they know what to do
and how to organize those how to think
about the world oh
uh you know i i i learned this at the
community center
i am responsible i have to clean this
space and take care of this and do my
homework and so forth and so on and i
have to prepare myself to move into the
larger world
and become a part of american society
fully
uh and educate myself and if i don't
i'm gonna suffer
and and but that's up to me i have the
opportunity absolutely to overcome that
absolutely well in a way you know we
really feel like this is our last stand
this is our stand against uh post-60
liberalism and we really do you've been
there since the beginning and and
we really feel like we're doing the
right thing and i want to thank you uh
for being with us and uh i want to thank
you for sharing your thoughts and
viewpoints and opinions here on rooftop
revelations and uh i appreciate what you
do so very much as you're a blessing to
not just me but people across america so
thank you for being on with us today
well it may sound like i'm putting the
syrup on the syrup
but i just want to emphasize i want to
emphasize
you are doing what i know what nobody
else is doing
uh i'm guilty sitting out here in
arizona
with warm weather and you're you're
sitting there but you are standing for
something
that is just enormous
and that is revolutionary the idea of
self-help
as the way for black america to overcome
its history of deprivation
that is a revolutionary idea that you
are the only one i know who's actually
down on the ground tried it
and you are due all due respect and
support
for that thank you
thank you i appreciate it so much listen
i hope you enjoyed our rooftop
revelations today it's been a blessing
thank you to mr steele thank you to eli
steele for producing the show thank you
to terrell for always filming even in
this cold weather we greatly appreciate
it and of course our guest today mr
steele it is a blessing to all of you in
america god bless you god bless america
and as i always say another rooftop
revelation until tomorrow peace
you